let me pick it off here Howard who would
you play in who would play you I should
say in Howard Marks the movie I think
Robin Williams really I've been told
that I look like Michael Douglas I've
been told that I look like Orson Bean if
you can remember that far back but when
I had a beard and Robin had a beard I
think we were dead ringers that's a
great guy
I love Dead Poets Society I was gonna go
George Clooney but alright Robin
Williams there you go
what is your top vacation spot your
favorite place to be your nirvana I like
to relax in a place called Majorca and
island off of Spain yeah I love mala a
lot of Germans there a lot of Germans
right well my watch last time you've
been June yes when I are free June this
year okay I will come with you
what about regrets your biggest invent
well I don't know if it's a regret
because he may learn something from a
but your biggest investment mistake my
biggest mistake was not being John
Paulson you know John Paulson had the
biggest most profitable trade in history
George Soros got famous for making a
billion of the weakness of the pound and
Paulson made fifteen billion but Paulson
existed I mean his bond existed what ten
years before that trade we didn't know
who he was it was a billion dollar fund
you've been chugging along since 1995
kicking butt you want to have just one
extraordinary hit well I'd like to fold
that into the rest of a huge grand slam
in the middle right all right who's your
favorite Howard of all the famous
Howard's out there and there are many we
went through this morning yes there are
my favorite Howard is Howard Marks ah
and if you google Howard Marks you'll
get you'll get Europe's biggest drug
smuggler oh yes that's true and and he's
my age almost exactly within a few
months the main difference between us is
that he's English he's Welsh the main
difference is that he's better educated
because he has a PhD from Cambridge and
he he did seven years inside hard time
and
I had him to my apartment you and though
you hold on you looked him up and
invited him over right you called him
and said Howard Marks its Howard Marks
no I had a friend of mine Matt Newberg
is a techie and I figured connect us and
he and he put us together and and I met
him and it was really interesting nice
guy nice guy picture together no did he
bring any drugs he wrote a book called
mr. nice and he yes he autographed it
for me
yes well I did give him my book there
you go alright last question we know you
don't have the same vice he does what's
your vice a guilty pleasure so to speak
moving from one house to another and and
decorating them and furnishing them you
love doing that you love doing that I
really creates I love living in a
beautiful environment I create I love
beauty and that's my creative outlet and
you do the design yourself no I I worked
with a fellow named Michael Smith that
we've worked together for over 20 years
Michael is you may criticize but Michael
is the White House decorator at the
moment and he's my great friend and
we've worked together for over 20 years
alright if Michael were to say to you
Howard would you like to come to the
White House I design the White House I
design your house come break bread with
the president what would you say to
Obama I'm I would say that he's what
everybody said in the first campaign
he's a great communicator
some people said of course that that was
all he was and and we we hope he's not
but I think he can communicate better I
think I don't think he makes his case
strongly enough he's not doing it well
anymore well I think since he took
office I don't think he I would have
liked to have seen him on TV saying my
fellow Americans that lines been used
but here's what's going on in the
country with the financial crisis here's
why we need a bailout here's why the
banks are important these kinds of
things I'd like him to be on TV saying
when when Congress refuses to raise the
debt ceiling it's not about spending
money it's about paying bills they
authorized expenditures and if they
refuse to raise the debt ceiling what
they're saying is we will spend the
money we just won't pay the bills the
last not right I like him out there on
that the latter he may have said the
former doesn't win votes the truth does
not always win you votes well they have
to the question is whether you care
about something other than just both